Ukrainian officials say Russia has
launched another intense series of
nighttime air attacks using drones and
missiles against targets across Ukraine
keeps military Administration says the
southern port city of Odessa was
targeted with especially Fierce strikes
authorities are calling the attacks a
hellish Onslaught meant to destroy the
possibility of shipping Ukrainian grain
from its ports these 12 people were
wounded in the attacks no deaths have
been reported
while Russian officials say a fire at a
military facility in Crimea caused the
closure of a highway and the evacuation
of 2200 civilians from four villages
thank you
foreign
[Music]